this is lucy james reading for author
justin clark if absolutely nothing else
be grateful to naraka bladepoint for
being one of a scant few battle royale
titles where getting one-shotted by
someone hiding in a shrub three football
fields away isn't a danger that by
itself makes it welcoming in a way the
genre tends to ignore but lurking
beneath that relative ease and
approachability is a shrewd game of
wusha inspired combat that demands far
more steel from its players and we're
not just talking about swords and spears
the basic premise of naraka bladepoint
involves a secret island where warring
gods once battled to their deaths and
warriors now battle for the smallest
part of the god's power but that story
all but evaporates after the tutorial
stage aside from some skimpy lore cards
for each character unlocked after
reaching a certain xp level all you
really need to know is you're on an
island of abandoned villages scattered
weapon caches and an undulating purple
wall of death that ushers 60 brave
warriors closer and closer together your
sole mission is to be the last person
standing by any and all means necessary
survival means combat but instead of the
usual pistols shotguns and assault
rifles you're primarily looking at melee
weapons ranged options do exist from
crossbows and slow firing muskets to
environmental hazards that can be
triggered by the right slice or shot at
the right time you also have a grappling
hook that not only allows you to zip
across the map and onto higher ground
but also harpoon and fly at opponents
attack on titan style aside from the
hook each ranged option exists to merely
soften up opponents from a distance as
they close in getting the big fat kill
involves getting up close and personal
with something sharp and here showdowns
with opponents have more in common with
dynasty warriors and soul calibur than
fortnite each weapon has a number of
melee combos fancy uppercuts charge
maneuvers and parries which is augmented
by power-up shards of jade you can
either find or purchase while out in the
field while button mashing the first
enemy you see works when you're starting
out there are currently bots thrown in
with actual players to ease you in at
first your first encounter with a player
who knows what they're doing will teach
you some brutal lessons you start
learning that your parry has a
sakura-like margin of success and even
that's predicted on a poorly explained
color system that tells you if your
character has the ability to parry a
specific attack altogether dodges are
effective but can easily be adjusted for
by a smart forward thinking player
you'll even run into the dreaded
mechanic of weapons and armor
degradation which sounds like the deal
breaker on paper however repair items
are widespread and the push and pull of
every player regardless of how skilled
they are needing to find respite in
order to be successful creates a rather
nice tension to every match you're
dealing with all of this while also
wondering if the next warrior to finish
you off hasn't been waiting in the trees
for you the whole time everyone is
vulnerable here as long as you catch
them at the right moment that's a solid
and exciting foundation to build a
battle royal game onto but like most
games of the sort there's a lot of
overhead room to grow there are a few
nitpicks with the game as a set of
mechanics the control scheme in
particular occupies an awkward middle
ground where actual combat is best with
a controller but equipping and switching
items and managing your loadout damn
near requires a mouse and keyboard and
switching back and forth effectively
feels awkward no matter how you decide
to configure the layout there are only a
few game modes at the moment a typical
battle royale mode with an option for
apex legend style trio matches included
and a free for all deathmatch mode
that's typically fine for a game that
has more going on mechanically or
narratively to keep you engaged but
that's just not where the game is at
right now and the grind can get a little
rote as a result right now the game's
biggest issue is one of personality the
world of morris island is absolutely
gorgeous a place of sun-kissed golden
valleys haunting shipwrecks and derelict
temples there are more than a few
moments so painterly and evocative of
chinese mythology and ancient art i had
to stop in my tracks to appreciate them
which typically resulted in someone i
didn't see deciding to try and snag a
free hit the environment of the game is
very much on point as far as immersion
goes
however characters are a different case
with only two exceptions the blind
swordsman viper ning and the possessed
witch yotohime the warriors of morris
island are rather generic martial
artists whose personalities don't shine
through visually or mechanically each
does have their own set of special moves
and an ultimate ability but many of them
are unwieldy in a hectic fight at least
until you've stuck it out with them
enough to unlock the far more effective
enhanced versions of those moves there
is some level of skin customization
where you can adjust a hero's face and
costumes to an extent but because there
isn't really a reason to care about
these people you're stuck making flimsy
cosmetic changes most of the options for
these changes are locked behind you
guessed it a loot system where there are
multiple currencies none of which are
fully explained and the most effective
way to earn them comes from spending
real money
naraka blade points ui is already a
cluttered mess of things you don't and
shouldn't worry yourself about until
you've put several hours into the game
but once you've put in the time to try
and understand you realize just how much
of the information boils down to
here are ways to spend coins and you'll
need a lot of them the good news is that
this doesn't apply to anything that
would make winning matches any easier as
you get xp no matter what and leveling
up to unlock each character's alternate
moves is fairly quick the bad news is
having to wade through all the other
noise to do so there are issues for sure
but this early in naraka bladepoint has
room to grow and iron out its kinks you
can see the potential more than the
problems when you're in the thick of it
grappling from rooftop to rooftop
clanging swords with enemies drums and
wind instruments filling the air as you
consider the best way to move in for the
kill there's a forethought and
shrewdness required to be successful
here that gives it a very different feel
than any other battle royale title
that's out there at the moment and the
ancient chinese aesthetic is a dazzling
one if nothing else it's enough to want
to see what the game looks and feels
like in the months to come
huh
[Music]
[Music]
behold the wages of defiance
[Music]